senator e.k ekrimadu
and Dr Beatrice ekrimadu you can remain
sitting for the for the moment
you have each been convicted of
conspiracy to commit an offense of human
trafficking
you brought a young man to London to
exploit him
the exploitation was the proposed
donation of a kidney for reward
the reward was to be the payment of
money and a chance to work in the United
Kingdom
people trafficking across International
borders
for the harvesting of human organs is a
form of slavery
it treats human beings
and their body parts as Commodities to
be bought and sold
it is a trade that preys on poverty and
misery and Desperation
the evidence shows that those who are
impoverished
often living in multi-dimensional
poverty
desperate for a better life
and ignorant of the true risks
are sometimes willing to donate their
organs
for money or the chance to work in the
UK
significant risks attached to such
donation without proper aftercare
you each played a part in that
despicable trade
you are being a better
underwent a kidney transplant at the
Royal free hospital in London in 2021
you said that you and your donor were
cousins
that was a lie
the clinicians at the Royal free
and the independent assessors at the
human tissue Authority
were taken in by your lie
they believed that the donor was acting
altruistically as a good samaritan
the transplant went ahead
there is no evidence that the donor has
been given the necessary aftercare
it is not necessary for me to make a
finding as to whether you exploited the
donor
but what is clear is that you learn from
your experience
that it was possible to manipulate and
corrupt the regulatory system
by using a fabricated affidavit
by lying about your relationship with
the donor
and by coaching the donor to lie
you Senator EK ramadu and you Dr
Beatrice EK ramadu have a daughter Sonia
she is very ill
she is suffering from
fsgs nephrotic syndrome
she needs a kidney transplant
everybody has enormous sympathy for her
and for the impact on each of you seeing
your daughters suffering
sonja's Uncle d-way ekramardu knew Ebina
abetta from medical school
he got in touch
being a better offered to help find a
donor
a possible donor was identified
by law his name may not be published
I will call him C
grew up in a village where he had no
electricity or running water
he left school at the age of 15.
and he went to Lagos where he sold phone
accessories from a wheelbarrow in a
market
he was earning about three and a half
thousand naira a day
the equivalent of just seven pounds
tests in Nigeria showed that his blood
group was the same as Sonya
he agreed to come to the UK
I am sure that he did not at any point
agree to donate a kidney to Sonia
altruistically
there was no reason why he should do so
he was not related to your family
he did not know Sonia or any other
member of your family
nothing was put in place to secure his
future health care needs
if he donated a kidney
the wealth and power inequality and
disparity
between you and C could not be more
marked
you eke ramadu are a senator in
Nigeria's National Assembly
you have held high political office
you had many staff
including domestic staff Maids chefs and
drivers
you own multiple properties around the
globe
there is evidence of as many as 40.
more than four hundred thousand pounds
went into your bank account over a
six-month period
by contrast C was unable to afford a 25
pound fare to travel from Lagos to Abuja
you each conspired together to bring sea
to the UK in order to exploit him
you all knew that was unlawful
had been part of the legislature that
had introduced the law that made that
conduct a criminal offense in Nigeria
you a are better secured the Visa
you did so by telling a lie that c and
Sonia were cousins
the same lie that you had told in
respect of you and your donor
you also secured a fabricated affidavit
testifying to their relationship as
cousins
just as you had done for your transplant
you asked the ekrimadu family to pay CFE
a fee of three and a half million naira
the jury rejected your account that the
fee was for his loss of earnings
the fee was paid by you Ike
the jury rejected your account that you
knew the fee was a scam
and that no reward would ever be paid to
see
the evidence suggests that a corrupt
relationship was established with a
member of Royal freeze staff
an interpreter who agreed to help with
quotes coaching the boy End quotes and
to provide the quotes relevant
interpretation End quotes
were instrumental in establishing and
controlling that corrupt relationship
the clinicians at the Royal free
hospital once again believed the
untruthful account that the donor and
recipient were cousins
there was however a concern about the
risk to see given his age and his
ethnicity
after the doctors interviewed him they
were concerned that he was not
sufficiently mature and motivated to be
an organ donor
this time the transplant was not
approved
there was no report to the safeguarding
team
and no report to the police
despite the indicators that the donor
was a victim of trafficking
those indicators included the tenuous
nature of the relationship between C and
Sonia
The Limited evidence to support that
relationship
and sees clear lack of understanding
about the process
and also his reaction to being told that
he was at the hospital to discuss a
kidney donation
in the course of the trial Hugh Davis KC
suggested that a lesson to be learned
from this case
is that clinicians must be alive to the
risk of trafficking
and Report cases like this when concerns
arise
I entirely agree
after the decision had been made that
the transplant would not go ahead
there was a Sinister development
a consultant nephrologist
and another man examined C at the place
where he was being kept
it is not necessary to make a finding as
to the true purpose of that examination
but it is easy to understand why C
believed that he was going to be taken
back to Nigeria for the transplant to be
conducted there
on the 3rd of May when C was due to
return to Nigeria he ran away
he spent two nights sleeping rough
on the 5th of May exactly a year ago he
attended Staines police station
there he saw Sonja Nicholas a police
inquiry officer
and detective Constable Hannah Paisley
as a result of them carefully listening
to see
it was recognized that he might be a
victim of trafficking
Arrangements were made to secure his
protection and his well-being
subsequently each of you was arrested
charged prosecuted and convicted
she suffered a loss of his personal
autonomy because you kept his passport
and exercise control over his movements
and his basic human needs
he was put in fear that he would be
subject to the forced removal of his
kidney without any appropriate aftercare
now he is scared to return home to
Nigeria
as he puts it he is having to start his
life again
I considered that a substantial
compensation order might well be
appropriate for the loss and damage he
has been caused by your conduct
I asked the crown to inquire as to seize
attitude towards such an order
that is because in some cases victims of
crime do not want compensation from the
offender
and an award of compensation might even
risk causing further distress
a police officer carefully explained the
meaning reason and purpose of a
compensation order to see
he immediately responded that he not did
not wish to entertain compensation
the officer says quotes
she spoke with moral conviction
despite understanding the material
benefit receiving compensation may have
for him
he adamantly said he did not need or
want anything from the bad people
he no longer wants them to have any
involvement with him
in any capacity
irrespective of the financial benefit he
stood to make
C said that he wanted to put this entire
ordeal behind him and move on with his
life
he believes this to be the right and
fair thing to do and quotes
two days later the officer spoke to C
again
he remained quotes Resolute with his
decision regarding compensation
and insisted he had not and did not wish
to change his mind on the subject End
quotes
of course I respect sees views
in the circumstances it is not
appropriate to make a compensation order
the crown seek an order for costs under
Section 18 of the prosecution of
offenses Act 1985.
I adjourn that application and will make
directions for its determination
in the case of each of you I impose the
statutory surcharge order in the sum of
190 pounds
in each of your cases the offense you
committed is so serious
that neither are fine
nor a community sentence can be
justified
a life sentence is not appropriate and I
do not consider that you are dangerous
so as to Merit the imposition of an
extended sentence
accordingly in each case I pass a
determinate custodial sentence
with the shortest term
that is commensurate with the
seriousness of the offense
taking account of the aggravating and
mitigating features
you will each serve part of the sentence
in custody before being released on
license
when you are released you will be on
license until the end of your sentence
you must comply with the terms of the
license and commit no further offenses
otherwise you will be liable to serve a
further period in custody
the disclosure and barring service will
include each of you in the list of those
who are barred from working with
vulnerable adults or children
you may ask the service to be removed
from the lists
the sentencing Council has published
guidelines for offenses of human
trafficking contrary to section 2 of the
modern slavery Act 2015.
you have each been convicted of
conspiracy to commit that offense
the offense that you committed is
closely related to the guideline offense
I reject the defense submissions that
the guidelines are not apt to cover this
particular form of trafficking
I have close regard to the guidelines
I turn to the question of harm
the transplant did not go ahead
but you each intended that it should go
ahead
and you each intended the harm to the
donor that would result
and which was eminently foreseeable
the donor would have faced invasive
surgery
with a small but still possible risk of
death
he would have faced spending the rest of
his life with only one kidney
and without any funding for the required
aftercare
he would have faced an increased risk of
early onset raised blood pressure
and of developing chronic kidney disease
later in life
as a as well as a lifetime risk of
needing dialysis himself
or even a kidney transplant
he was at an increased risk because of
his young age and his ethnicity
the removal of a kidney amounts to
serious physical harm which has a
substantial and long-term effect
even if she had known that he was going
to donate a kidney I am sure that the
risks had not been properly explained to
him before he was brought to the UK
he was deceived and pressurized into
donating a kidney
I reject the defense assertions that he
consented in any meaningful sense
I am sure that he did not
there has been a substantial and
long-term adverse impact on his daily
life
he is scared to return to Nigeria
because of the risk of Retribution from
those that are sympathetic to you
he lives a solitary existence and is
separated from his life his friends and
his family as a direct result of this
offense
this all amounts to Category 2 harm
within the meaning of the sentencing
council's guidelines
I do not accept the crown submission
that the nature and extent of the harm
justifies a movement to category one
but it does warrant an upwards
adjustment within the category range
the fact that the transplant was not
carried out merits a downwards
adjustment
but the level of that adjustment is
limited
because firstly the graverman of the
offense is the agreement that you
reached to exploit the donor
the offense was complete at that point
the offense focuses on the conduct of
the offender rather than the harm that
is caused to the victim
secondly you did not withdraw from the
conspiracy
the only reason that the transplant did
not take place
was because the hospital refused to
carry it out
in each case your reaction was to seek
to exploit others
and thirdly quite apart from the harm
that would have resulted from a
transplant C has resulted has suffered
substantial actual harm of the nature
that I have identified
I turn to culpability
you are being a better fall within the
high culpability bracket
you played a leading role in the
offending
you identified the donor and controlled
him throughout the process
you did so in the expectation of
substantial Financial reward
I reject your assertion that there's no
evidence of substantial financial
advantage
your bank statements show otherwise
and demonstrate that you were reliant on
the funds you secured from the ekramadu
family
to keep your head above water
you applied a high degree of planning
and premeditation
for example you arranged the Visa
you secured a fabricated affidavit
and you organized a scheme to seek to
deceive the clinicians
and ultimately the human tissue
Authority
you were thoroughly dishonest throughout
you kept a substantial sum of money that
was paid by EK EK ramadu and was
intended for the donor
also fall within the high culpability
bracket
you also played a leading role in the
offending and to a greater extent than
obina or better
who was acting through d-way paramadu at
your direction
you did so in order to secure a material
advantage namely a human kidney for your
daughter
you were involved in a high degree of
planning and premeditation
for example you orchestrated the
arrangements with your brother d-way
you sought to conceal your link to the
payment of a donor reward
by instructing a member of your staff to
make the payment via a currency Trader
you were involved in the corruption of a
member of hospital staff
I reject the defense suggestion that you
are naive as to offers or payments of a
reward to the donor or that you only
joined the conspiracy at a late stage
I am satisfied so that I am sure that
you were the driving force throughout
Reliance is placed on the fact that you
had no contact with C or abena a better
that is true
but it is an indicator of the leading
role you played directing the overall
operation
but keeping your distance by getting
others to do your bidding
I accept that you are not directly
involved in the fabrication of an
affidavit
and that you told Sonia not to sign it
again in context that is consistent with
the type of leading role you played
you well knew the sorts of steps that
were being taken to try and pull the
wool over the eyes of the doctors and
regulators
I am satisfied that you Beatrice
performed more limited functions under
the direction of your husband
I accept the submission of a new
mahindru King's Council that your family
was patriarchal and you were deferential
to your husband
your role was primarily to adopt the
cousin lie
there was so far as you are concerned
some limited planning and free
meditation
you committed the offense and the
expectation of a material advantage
namely securing a kidney for your
daughter
your case Falls at the cusp of lower and
medium culpability
before allowing for aggravating and
mitigating factors
the applicable starting points are
custodial sentences of 10 years in the
case of abena are better
10 years and six months in the case of
AKA Madu and six years in the case of
Beatrice ekrimaju
Ebina a better stand up please
there are aggravating features in your
case
you deliberately targeted a victim who
was particularly vulnerable
due to his young age
his isolation from his immediate family
and his poverty
after the conspiracy to exploit C was
thwarted you continued to try and find
another person to be exploited in the
same way
as against that you have no previous
convictions and you were a person of
good character
I accept that you have done much good
work as a medical doctor
you also have your own serious medical
condition
as someone who is himself undergone a
kidney transplant
I've taken account of the medical
evidence
that does not suggest that your
condition cannot be adequately managed
in custody
I consider that the mitigating and
aggravating factors are in balance
I sentence you to 10 years imprisonment
subject to allowing for the time for
which you've been remanded in custody
you will spend two-thirds of that time
in custody and will then be on license
until the end of your sentence you can
sit down please
Senator EK ramadu stand up please
there are substantial aggravating
features in your case
you knew that the donor was vulnerable
because of his young age and his poverty
you had a profound understanding of the
impact of poverty because of the work
you have done for the ecoa foundation
you gave direct instructions to ensure
that tight control was exercised over
sea
once the transplant did not go ahead you
immediately sought to find another
person to be exploited in the same way
rapidly managing to identify several
potential candidates
as against that you have your own
ongoing health problems
you have no previous convictions
and were a person of good character
I accept Mr Hicks KC's description of
you as having exceptionally positive
good character
and that your conviction represents a
very substantial Fall From Grace
you set up the ecoa foundation
and have funded that organization
which undertakes a very great deal of
valuable charitable work to help those
living in poverty in Nigeria
at trial there was a great deal of
character witness testimony
including from Archbishop Emmanuel
chukwuma the Archbishop for the Diocese
of enugu
I have been provided with a bundle of 51
pages of character statements for the
purpose of sentencing
I have read all of them
they include statements from a former
president of Nigeria
the current president of the Senate
the bishop of enugu
the attorney general and the chief law
officer of Nigeria
and the Speaker of the House of
Representatives
that evidence speaks to your role in
helping to establish and maintain
democracy in Nigeria and also as an
international Peacemaker
the evidence also includes moving please
Advanced by some of those who have
benefited from your generosity and good
works
and also a moving statement from your
daughter Sonia
I take all of that into account
it amounts to substantial mitigation
you were motivated by the despair of
your daughter's very serious illness
the weight to be attached to that factor
is limited by reason of the fact that as
you recognized in your evidence you
could have sought a genuinely altruistic
donation
including from a family member albeit
not Sonia's immediate siblings
after taking account of the aggravating
and mitigating factors in your case
I impose a sentence of nine years and
eight months imprisonment
subject to allowing for the time which
you have spent remanded in custody
you will serve two-thirds of the
sentence in custody and will be in light
unlicensed thereafter for the rest of
the sentence
can sit down
not to be a Beatrice would you stand up
please
in your case I adopt a starting point of
six years custody
I do not consider that the aggravating
factors that are present in the case of
your co-defendants apply to you
you were not directly involved in the
identification of the donor
and the evidence does not show that you
are directly involved in the attempts to
identify a further donor after the
transplant did not go ahead
I take account of all the mitigating
features that Mr mahendru Casey has
identified
and the content of the thorough and
helpful pre-sentence report
prepared by Jessica Stephen of the
probation service
you are a person of good character
you helped set up the ecoa foundation
with your husband
and you have been closely involved with
its important charitable work
much of the character evidence I have
read applies also to you
you were also motivated by the desperate
plight of your daughter
and by maternal love
further in your case I accept that
although Sonia is an adult you have
substantial caring responsibilities
towards her
your incarceration will have a
significant impact on her
in that she will no longer be able to
rely on your presence as a source of
care and support
having regard to those factors I impose
a sentence of four years and six months
imprisonment
you have spent 234 days on an
electronically monitored curfew between
9 pm and 7 00 am
I specify that the credit period for the
purposes of section 240 a of the
criminal justice act 2003 is 117 days
so that period shall count towards your
sentence
subject to that and subject to allowing
for the time you have spent through
marketing custody you will serve one
half of your sentence income
will then be unlicensed thereafter for
the rest of the sentence
you can now each be taken downstairs